une consommation idéal d'alcool dans
l'absolu c'est zéro vers et aussi la
consommation idéal de soda par exemple
dans l'absolu mais dans la vraie vie
comment ça se passe ouais parce que bon
zéro vers on se comprend quoi donc on va
plutôt essayer de comprendre ce que
c'est une consommation raisonnable
d'alcool et surtout commenté paul harris
[Musique]
déjà ça veut dire quoi raisonnable une
consommation raisonnable d'alcool c'est
réussir à boire de l'alcool en évitant
les deux principaux problèmes qui a avec
cette substance à savoir les problèmes
de santé et la diction la dépendance les
problèmes de santé en question c'est des
cancers des maladies cardiovasculaires
des troubles neurologiques ou
psychologique des atteintes du foie etc
sans parler des prises de risque qu'on a
tendance à avoir quand on a bu on peut
citer les accidents de voiture et le
sexe sans protection pour avoir juste
deux exemples concrets mais il y en a
pleins d'eau les risques d'avoir des
problèmes de santé il augmente avec la
quantité d'alcool qu'on voit donc une
consommation raisonnable c'est une
consommation qui limite la quantité mais
avec les problèmes d'addiction c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué que ça donc il
faut aussi limiter la fréquence à
laquelle on boit de l'alcool pour éviter
de lui faire une place dans notre vie
quotidienne
les experts se sont mis d'accord sur les
chiffres le risque acceptable sans se
priver complètement c'est l'hiver deux
boissons alcoolisées par semaine parfois
de deux par jour et pas tous les jours
et alors quand on dit un verre de
boisson alcoolisée on se base sur les
doses qui sont servis dans les bars
sympas les verts de creat que vous
servez en soirée et pour être tout à
fait complet sur le sujet on est bien
d'accord
une pointe c'est que vers la base c'est
le domicile commencez pas à négocier
c'est pas l'happy hour de la santé
haïtien
alors c'est bien joli tout ça en corse
n'ont pas toujours mais bref
en vrai comment on fait parce que si est
raisonnable c'était si facile ça serait
pour commencer l'idéal fait de se
retirer de la tête que boire un verre
avec des potes c'est forcément boire un
verre d'alcool
oui alors je sais comment c'est pas
assez facile à dire mais gardez bien ça
en fait ça va faciliter la suite du coup
l'autre idée c'est de pavaner un pote
qui commente pas un verre d'alcool quand
vous
avec lui fait pas semblant vous savez
quoi je parle ensuite évidemment je vais
vous donner quelques petits conseils
pratiques
ne buvez pas d'alcool si vous avez juste
soif du v en soft de l'eau par exemple
c'est vachement bien l'eau en plus
l'alcool ça des hydrates donc de toutes
façons à terme ça va nous donner de plus
en plus soif quand vous faites la fête
ne buvait pas que de l'alcool au bar au
resto en soirée alterner un verre
d'alcool un verre de soft en plus ça va
vous aider à lutter contre la
déshydratation qui est aussi responsable
de la gueule de penser à manger de
l'alcool sur un estomac vide c'est la
pire idée à tous points de vue
et puis en plus bas pendant que vous
mangez vous suivez moi forcément
prenez votre temps c'est pas une course
duvet lentement et attendait un petit
peu avant de commander le vert suivant
déjà alterné avec des verres de soft
comme on a dit et si vraiment j'avais du
mal à gérer l'espace entre deux verres
fixez vous un temps précis mettez vous
un timer si vous avez besoin
ne buvez pas tous les jours au moins
deux jours dans la semaine sans alcool
c'est le minimum
n'hésitez pas à noter les jours de la
semaine où vous avez vu et combien de
verres vous avez vu comme ceux ci c'est
marrant mais on a tendance à facilement
mieux surtout quand on a bu ne buvez pas
seul
là encore l'idée c'est de ne pas laisser
entrer l'alcool dans notre vie
quotidienne des occasions de voir il y
en a déjà des caisses donc fixé vous
cette règle absolue quand je suis seul
je ne bois pas d'accord ne buvait pas si
vous n'en avez pas envie
en clair buvait pas parce que vous vous
sentez obligé ou parce que vous avez
l'impression que vous en avez besoin
ça veut dire aussi buvais quand vous
allez bien pas quand vous allez mal
d'abord parce que ça risque de devenir
un réflexe et ensuite parce que ça
risque de créer plus de problèmes que ça
n'en résout vu que ça ne résout jamais
si vous avez besoin d'un coup de main
il ya des applis qui peuvent vous aider
mais on est d'accord et surtout sur les
derniers points qu'on vient de voir ça
peut être difficile d'être vraiment
lucide sur sa propre situation
et puis c'est compliqué de se
dépatouiller tout seul donc si on sent
qu'on a du mal à gérer
c'est important de se pencher
sérieusement sur la question avec un
généraliste avec un psy avec un
spécialiste avec des centres de
consultation dans un premier temps vous
pouvez déjà aller vous renseigner sur
alcoolinfoservice pointer ou au 09 180
180 930 ouais parce qu'attention là ce
que je vous dis c'est pour apprendre à
consommer raisonnablement mais en vrai
il ya peut-être déjà défini qui montrent
que votre consommation
elle est déjà problématique si vous
voulez savoir où vous en êtes avec
l'alcool vous pouvez faire un test pour
évaluer votre consommation sur al
commettre point fr il ya zéro place pour
le jugement là dedans c'est juste que la
france ça fait partie des plus gros pays
en matière de consommation d'alcool
donc c'est bien de savoir où on en est
pour le savoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]